kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are deep in wedding planning and talking
about having babies together i love it a
source tells et that the two are so in
love that they are open to the idea of
having children together and growing
their family adding that both of their
families are supportive of the idea and
just want the couple to be happy
i love you
[Music]
of course the 42 year old pooch founder
shares three kids with her ex scott
disick 12 year old mason nine-year-old
penelope and seven-year-old reign so
let's get the names you are
penelope
mason what's your name
rain
as for the 46 year old blink 182 drummer
he shares two teens with his ex shayna
mokler 18 year old landon and 16 year
old alabama
came a long way from pre-k and eating
lunchables i just took your life and as
you know it's unrefundable when you up
the smith and you should never feel
uncomfortable and earlier this week
shayna told et that if her kids pop up
on the kardashian family's upcoming hulu
reality series she's all for it
i won't be tuning in
however
um you know i think it's fine if you
know this is an opportunity that they
want to be a part of and you know my
main concern is always you know my my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
travis and i you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
the kardashians are good to my kids you
know that's all that matters to me as a
mom you know as long as they're happy
and then you know that's that's the key
fans speculate that landon in alabama
will be featured on the show after
landon shared this video from his dad's
engagement dinner
right there that's a camera crew filming
the whole thing
and speaking of weddings e.t source says
court and travis have been deep in
planning mode adding that the reality
star has been including her family in
the plans but definitely wants to be in
control at the same time quote she has a
very specific vision and wants to share
that with travis first before leaning on
the rest of her family for advice
the musician popped the question back in
october and now our source says the plan
is to get married sooner than later
adding that they want the wedding to be
really exclusive intimate and special
quote courtney is super excited to get
married to travis both courtney and
travis are so looking forward to
spending the rest of their lives
together as soul mates
[Music]